welcome back to new rock stars one
division finale is imminent
with a staggering number of questions
left to be answered
wanda is facing the witchcraft of agatha
and maybe an opportunity to escape
into a multiverse but monica rambo could
be our hero new jersey's radiation
levels are
well maybe the same as they were before
but how will
this end i'm eric voss this is rogue
theory with me today is an amazing panel
uh including editor and chief of geeks
of color dorian parks
thanks for having me back guys excited
to be here again excited to have you
back this could be great uh also coming
back to new rockstars a friend of the
show comedian
danielle spiso hi guys not dressed up as
wednesday
adams maybe next time i'm a little
disappointed
that it's a deep crack viewers yeah
remember the old days the good times no
the good times are happening right here
right now because we got marvel stuff
to talk about oh and who can forget
off-screen producer zach huddleston's
here
hey happy to be on screen again i
am dressed as wednesday adam this time
so that's
costume lose a couple points it's more
of a mindset
than a yeah it's an interpretative one
all right so as we turn
toward the we assume a final battle of
one division here
the options are really narrowing for how
this series will conclude
like how will it set up the next marvel
titles how will it rewrite the rules of
the mcu
let's do this together guys let's set
some predictions for this one division
finale episode
so uh i want to hear all you guys
thoughts on this first let's talk about
this
dawn of the multiverse that we might be
facing do
we think that we will see wanda actually
create the mcu multiverse
and have we already seen that process
and
its process already started i think so i
mean she's
losing it and i don't think she really
has control
over like exactly what she's doing and i
could see her just like
i'm gonna say it maybe the vision dies
and that just snaps her little crazy
brain and there there we go there goes
the nexus and it's just like
looping all over the place maybe
maybe agatha harkness is trying to keep
that all
intact maybe she's not a bad guy after
all guys oh that's a hot take i
said not the village she's the one
trying to keep wanda
the villain from blowing everything up
maybe maybe i
i i don't know i personally think i i
would like to see like the the hex or
whatever just
keep continually to expand and expand
and expand and maybe it just
takes over the whole world and that's
kind of how we get like the house of him
because
she was already kind of like anybody
that enters gets their
their cells rewritten so maybe the hex
just keeps expanding like like daniel
said like maybe she snaps
that causes her to just fully just break
out the full expansion across the whole
globe and that's why we have doctor
strange in the mix and then he's like
hey girl wanda what are you doing like
what's going on right now so
that's kind of how i think this is
leaning towards like just a a major hex
expansion and one of my friends said
like
instead of calling them the x-men we
just start to call him the hex man
i love that i love hex-men oh
how have i not thought of that that's
amazing um
no uh dorian that's a that's a really
good idea because like uh
why did the hex stop at its expansion
point that it did you know it's
that farm was like whatever eight miles
outside west view
like what did i want to just get tired
or she's like
that's good we got the sword camp in
there we got vision it looks like a lot
of work
to expand the heck so girl's got to take
a break you know
yeah but like if uh if she wanted to it
seemed like the implication of that
episode six final scene was that it
could just keep going
like it could go it could coat the
entire world
uh it didn't really seem to go as far to
uh see a curvature on the world
that is if you subscribe to the theory
that the world is actually around
but uh it seemed like it could just keep
going out and out and now
and coat the entire you know the thing
is people don't know i'm joking so i got
to be clear that that was a joke
i really some of our subscribers are of
the conspiracy persuasion
um the world is not flat uh but in the
mcu it might be
i don't know maybe it's a hexagon shape
it could be hex shaped you're right
daddy um zach what do you think the
multiverse uh dawn could look like in
this show
i do think here's what i think i think
you mentioned a post-credits scene
i think we haven't seen a multiverse yet
right we thought we had we got teased
with multiverse when
when uh evan peters showed up but um
turned out that that's probably not fox
quicksilver showing up but it was maybe
just a quirk of casting we'll talk about
that later
i think we get maybe in the post-credits
scene
i think wanda is going to want to escape
this earth
and so somehow then maybe as a result of
the final battle somehow you know a
little hole opens up
that she jumps through and that's like
her escaping into the multiverse and we
only get a tiny glimpse of it
and then it gets fully explored in
doctor strange too multiverse
of madness i feel like we know that um
scarlet witch is going to show up in
doctor strange too but they're not gonna
want these
to feel like nine episodes and then a
movie that are all one continuous story
i feel like the multiverse story is
going to be told
in doctor strange too yeah we'll just be
kind of teased just a
tiny hint at it at the end of this to
keep up
keep us intrigued until that film comes
out yeah i agree and and
i think zach and dorian you guys are are
right there about like it's
this is setting up a real conflict a
multiverse conflict in doctor strange i
think that much is clear and i think
the house of m elements of the story is
really gonna be
more uh adapted in in this dr strange
movie um but i think in the meantime we
are seeing this kind of origin story for
monica rambo and there's still so we
just released a video
uh on this yesterday but like the idea
is like
it seems like monica rambo has some ties
to swords sometimes with carol danvers
that she might
have already been superpowered before
she passed through these walls a few
times and that's why
she has these photon abilities now but
like uh
so what do you think is being set up
with uh with photon with monica rambo if
photon is going to be her
her name i mean is there oh sorry i'm
going to connect you go ahead
oh no i'm just i'm just so excited
because we talked about this off camera
but when they started this series like
with her introduction i was like all
right are they going to actually give
her her powers are they going to
actually like
dive into her backstory i thought like
she was just gonna be a side character
not such a
central focus to the storyline so i'm
like damn they're really setting up this
hero so i was
i was visually blown away when she like
passed through and actually like
became and got those powers but now i'm
thinking like does she go by the moniker
of photon
because that's her mom or will she like
will they change it up and do like
call her spectrum but i definitely think
they're setting her up to
to be a hero and maybe it's her and
scarlett versus agatha in the finale
because
when we see when you see that like post
credit scene of her eyes glowing
at first i thought it was uh i thought
it was agatha controlling her but
after i like if you take a look like i
pause it you can see her eyes are
starting to glow like
before uh quicksilver pietro even shows
up so i think that was just
her her powers reacting to what was
going on and not necessarily her being
controlled so i'm like
maybe she can take whatever those blasts
are being dealt to her with like the
mind control when she will be able to
like really snap wanda out of it and be
like
hey wanda let's go ahead and fight this
agatha and beat her up and like take her
down because she's about to destroy the
world or something but i definitely
think that
they're setting her up to be one of the
people to kind of help wanda
find her way back to the light and not
like you know
go completely evil i feel like the
scrolls could really come
into play i know that's kind of like a
theory that people are throwing around
that major goodner is actually a scroll
and maybe they i mean they're super
super loyal to
monica and her mom and maybe they and
they are
there is a show coming out about the
scrolls yeah
they're trying to like tease that and
tie that all in you know how much they
love their connections
yeah so yeah that's a interesting point
because think about it it seems like
this show could potentially set up like
eight or nine different upcoming marvel
things like we have doctor strange and
multiverse
madness wanda's coming back in that
right but then we also have captain
marvel 2.
uh monica rambo is coming back in that
uh we have secret invasion so
all the scroll stuff seems like it could
be setting up that we have
potentially fantastic four and x-men
that are being set up in this show
it's is it possible all i care about is
a darcy and agent will spin off like
yeah right from this series and they are
doing something wrong right now
yeah that's the one i'm focusing on a
west view
csi with just darcy and jim and jimmy
or they become roommates and it's just a
fun sitcom comedy where they're
roommates
that's all i need just watching tv shows
and darcy has to kind of explain to
jimmy and he's like can we just put on
ncis
i really like those guys no i think like
the fact that we have all these things
that are being set up it's
there's got to be some kind of
multiverse angle like uh
imagine some kind of like huge big grid
of spectrums and each one has like a
different one of these new shows that's
being set up
because while i can see how multiverse
of madness is being set up or even
loki's being set up because those both
seem kind of like bonkers
douglas adamsy and weird things like
what does this say for the falcon winter
soldier
or for miss marvel or for shang chi or
eternals
and the only way those kind of makes
sense in a multiverse as if they just
are in their own self-contained genres
undisturbed by other weird things coming
from other dimensions
and she's just like hey i'm in a world
where there's a fighting tournament i'm
locked in a battle with this guy
called the mandarin and i you know i
that's just it's its own genre and
that's how kevin feige might be trying
to justify it of like
the reason we haven't seen this fighting
tournament world yet is because
it's within another genre dimension that
wanda is about to create if that gives
us an excuse to introduce angel shield
and make them actually canon yeah in the
shows then i would be more than fine
they have been doing my show dirty
acting like it doesn't exist outside
yeah its own series so if that's her if
that's like the excuse that they can
kind of have like daisy johnson in them
like kind of be sword agent or something
i'm all for it man
it's dorian let's talk about agents of
shield for a second because we keep
getting these little references in one
division
that gotta be agents of shield
references hydra soak right that is
totally
colson talking about the hydra soap mind
control and the framework
the the hula dancer uh dashboard
ornament like
why would they be making these little
references to agents of shield and then
not fold it into the multiverse right or
they're just trying to appease dorian
and the likes i mean maybe they knew
they knew i was going to be watching if
they're like i'm like
i'm aiding your show's number one fan
but you know and i think it they
reported or something that because in
the season finale series finale of aiden
shachill like
daisy and the crew are up in space and
they wanted to use sword but you know
because one division was using sword
they couldn't use the actual name so i
don't know maybe like they are trying to
slowly loosely tie those connections
because imagine that like agent wu
and agent coulson bantering together
like however the ultimate team up man so
i don't know
maybe the the multiverse can be the the
key that really
connects agent shield and the runaways
to the
mcu as a whole because i'm sure we're
talking about it but like the dark hold
i think that is the dark hold has been
mentioned a couple times on these other
shows so i would love for
some internet connectivity with the swan
division yeah what's hard is that like
as of right now when we when we're
taping this show it seems like the evan
peters pietro
isn't maybe necessarily a link like or
at least a hard link that
that however pietro got in this will be
the same way deadpool will get into this
necessarily
but like i do want the implication of
this finale to be
that all these different things we've
seen could be kind of loosely connected
or folded in in different ways like if
it's just like the promise of it the
implication of it i don't need answers
right now you know
we can make these stupid videos on new
rock stars that kind of guess that
answers for the next couple months
but just like give us a promise of
something you know they'll never make
promises make sense too because it takes
place
after or it takes place before far from
home and you know like
they didn't pull that multiverse
reference out of nowhere so i feel like
whatever
the season finale whatever ends in one
division will definitely
have a multiverse implications because
they wouldn't have mentioned that
at all in sparta in spiderman like they
i don't know where he would have pulled
that from so
who knows i i like that idea and and
that's a great like reference to bring
up
far from home so i will say like the
thing i keep thinking about with this
show and like
how big of an impact it's going to have
on the greater mcu it's like
this show's literally taking place
inside a bubble
like a literal bubble and i think
they're doing that for a reason
right this is like a this whole show is
a bottle episode
right and i think like yeah we get like
this character from ant-man and we get
this character from the thor movies and
and we get these characters that are
gonna go on to do stuff but i
i really think it's a self-contained
show and like whatever the end result of
this is not gonna have
as like broad a sweeping impact
and like they won't be able to tie
everything into this show but that's
just my thing well the nice thing about
the multiverse is they can literally
justify
anything because of it and you know
ultimately they want to make money
so whatever is going to make them the
most amount of money i think they'll
figure out how to justify
creating all sorts of shows and movies
yeah
um let's make some uh some final bets
here with like uh survival
bets you know do we think vision billy
tommy do we think any of them might
survive this show
i don't i don't think the the the
versions of billy and tommy we see now i
don't think those kids
are making it out of the show we might
we maybe we might see like an older
version like them speed and wick and
like coming to their full moniker like
fully
teenagers down the line but i think we
will not see those kids walking out of
this show
and i don't think we'll see fish and
walking out of the show either that
hurts me to say that but my boy i don't
i don't think my boy is making it out
he was built to die over and over again
yeah yeah i know i know i said that i
thought agatha wasn't the true villain
of the show
but i do think she may have eaten the
twins already
okay but that's not bad that's not a
deal breaker for you yeah
right no you're still a good guy
are they even really kids let's be real
yeah yeah they're probably like magic
yeah i think i think she whipped those
kids up into a twin sweet pie
and snacked on her before i've been i've
been working at work
[Laughter]
she wrote that last week um yeah i
i i totally agree and i i like what
dorian said that like
yeah those two kids are not going to be
wicked in speed but it does feel like we
are going to get a wicked speed
maybe is it like in the next episode
like they they walk outside the bubble
or wanda snaps your fingers or something
like that and all of a sudden
it's like two actors from riverdale or
something like that it's like oh yeah
that's who they want
to keep being big characters in the mcu
you know
and i also agreed that like yeah
vision's done right like that feels like
he's a he's a phase three character we
said goodbye to a lot of those
characters right it's time to move on to
phase four
we need these young new characters like
monica and wicken and speed and all this
kind of stuff so like he's kind of
helping with that transition but he's
probably done
and disney was probably like you know
after starting to film this they're like
you know it's too much of a hassle to
keep keeping up with kids like you know
there's a lot of rules so
they probably realized they were like we
are not going to try to make a whole
we're not trying to make them these kids
the younger vendors let's just agent
which is
maybe a couple years they'll recast them
but they were like no that's let's
end this here let's let's let's stop it
now yeah they need to get those cute
teams in there for all the
you know teeny boppers td boppers
you've workshop twins meat
no that one still working out but i
think we're
we're all on the same page that in order
to set up juan to kind of blow up the
multiverse she has to like
have these loved ones torn away from her
and
tommy and billy i love these kids
playing the parts i think they're really
good
but uh i think like while they hopefully
these actors will continue to get work
as a result of the show
and maybe in the mcu going forward i
think like
the multiverse of madness is gonna be
wanda desperately jumping from
multiverse to multiverse trying to find
this
that what she had in one division and
she's not gonna be successful
it's just gonna be each one's gonna be
slight it's gonna be like homer with the
uh
the toaster every little feature that
she goes to visits just gonna be off in
some weird way she's like not this one
um and that's gonna have like weird you
know cataclysmic side effects that
doctor train's gonna be like uh all
right someone needs to stop this
um but poor vision i hope i mean this
has been my favorite vision story i hope
paul bettany can continue to play some
version of this character
even if it's just like a rebooted jarvis
by the end of this you know i'd love to
see him come back as jarvis
maybe they'll do a season two and just
do like maybe one just like they
somehow the bubble is still remaining
and she says like
although i can't stay inside this bubble
because i have like real grown-up stuff
to do
in the real world she's like i'll i'll
keep this bubble alive for vision so for
the sake of it
and then she's she realizes like i have
to move on from vision and then she
creates his
he has his own little family and then we
have like vision family and then he can
just yeah live happily ever
oh cool and that's season two yeah yeah
i don't know i'm trying to be optimistic
but
yeah i i truly think he's not making
that uh yeah this series
yeah that's an interesting question uh i
think was loki announced to get a second
season but
are these other shows are we gonna get
season twos of these shows or is it
gonna be like
you know the way comics are adapted you
get a run of a storyline
and then that storyline flows into
another storyline close into another
storyline what do you guys think
could we get a true season two one
division i don't know but i i personally
think they
like they they see the hit like this
isn't the number one tv show out in the
world right now like why wouldn't you
come back and try to do a season two of
it like like you said there's different
comic book
adaptations like give us a one division
season two where she's just all happy
all the time i don't know
yeah i do like that idea of like you
could have a second season but treat it
like a comic book run so it has a
different title
maybe some of the same characters but
it's a totally different kind of story
right and you're not like stuck needing
to repeat the same
story you've already told and you have
the freedom to totally go somewhere else
and it's all wanda in space
or it's yeah just like the ghost
division
his story of his own wanda how he
visions wanda like it's a robot one i
don't know
put me in the writers room though i
don't care
yeah i don't see a true season two but i
i definitely see them spinning
off everything they're setting up and
allowing there to be
another show that takes all of this into
consideration
in this universe so uh i want to end by
just asking you guys do we think there's
going to be some kind of post-credit
stinger to this series and will it
introduce us to this uh
cameo that paul betty keeps teasing i
really think it's gonna be benedict
cumberbatch
peeking in at the end a little
post-credit
scene to just really set up the
splitting
or the opening of the multiverse and
kind of setting up doc
strange to um if they can't afford it i
don't know
it's probably pretty pricey somebody got
that disney money they can afford them
i think maybe so my money's on like
daniel said probably benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange making an
appearance but
also somebody in my mind like because
paul benny said it's somebody he's
always wanted to work with like no
disrespect to
uh no disrespect to benedict cumberbatch
but you know he's out compared to like
uh ian mcgregor or or or um patrick
stewart he's
he's no he's young like he still has a
career he has to build up to so
paul bendy is like his peer compared to
somebody of that caliber so i feel like
it has to be somebody like a professor x
maybe
the post-credits scene you see you see
professor x rolling up to the the hex or
something or he's like
what the hell is this like because i
feel like they've already hinted at the
like
you you see billy he already says like
he has those telepathic issues where he
can hear everybody he's he hears a lot
of noise
and he says like it's quiet now and so i
feel like they're hinting at
telepathy is a big thing so who who's
like the the main telepathy person
telepathic what's the word i'm trying to
tell my dumb ass the main telepathic
person you know
you know patrick stewart you know
professor x or jean grey but my money's
on professor x showing up
or magneto somebody well it has to be an
actor that's like relatively old for
paul benny to be like i've always wanted
to work with them
in my mind i think you're right
dorian it's someone who he regards with
respect and uh he might respect benedict
cumberbatch and i think benedict
cumberbatch
might totally cameo in this but i don't
think that is
the cameo he might be a cameo right uh
and i i did make a video about this and
someone's like well you know paul
bettany
and benedict cumberbatch were in uh that
that darwin movie together
they were in a movie together before so
i got excited to work
he well he would be uh excited to have
him on he might be a cameo just not the
cameo so that's why they yeah dorian i
think you're right on that zach what do
you think
okay so i i have i see both i like both
your ideas i raise you one
i got two cameos okay the first one
is maybe not the luke skywalker level
one but i think it could be a fun mcu
cameo
chiwuto oggia four i always mispronounce
his name but baron
right like we know he's connected to
dr strange he's hunting down all the
people with magic
right there's too many damn wizards in
this world or whatever his great line
was
everybody and there's so many damn
wizards in this world um
so like i wouldn't doubt because like
that's a kind of a
great actor uh paul bettany has never
been in a movie with him before even
though they're
both about the same age they're both
english actors um i think that could be
a fun like
talk about fireworks like if they're
like fighting each other with crazy
magic and lasers and stuff like that
but i think maybe the luke skywalker
level actor
i do think it could be whoever's playing
mephisto
and here's my pitch now this is this is
this is rogue
okay i think coming out of retirement
a an 80 plus year old gene hackman as
mephisto
okay he completes the circle he's in
both the superman movie as lex luthor
in like 1978 not a circle though
no of course he had a wiggle line
they do those like blurring effects on
his face
they d agents younger yeah yeah you know
maybe because it's it's they they
introduced like a little circus scene
last time maybe it's you see hugh
jackman they do a little cameo with him
in in a tent like it's his
his role as pt barnum or whatever
[Music]
they are fighting but then it ends in a
musical number and that's how they all
get along at the end
listen this girl has been doing some
crazy stuff
hey it's disney now so you never know
with disney they love a musical
oh my god um well i
have some points to award for this round
because this is still rogue theory and
i'm still a nerd who
calculates algorithmic points that i
award to people based on how much i like
what they just said
uh so zack for your take that uh this
could all be a literal bottle episode i
love that idea so
you get one uh sparkle buck there um
danielle you pitched this idea of agatha
maybe not being such a bad guy
also you said twins meat pie so for that
i
award you two points two points to
danielle
dorr um and then dorian you were all
over the place with some great hot takes
here
uh between hexman bringing in agents of
shield into this
uh season two being called visions wanda
oh i want to see that
listen man so if they don't bring me in
the writer's room for season two i'm
suing disney
higher than the warriors but i'm suing
them
uh hire this man uh and i'm gonna award
you three
points but it's still a nuanced game
because we got more to talk about with
uh
what the hell is pietro then uh so a
quick word real quick from the folks who
help bring rogue theory to you
every week first we want to thank our
friends at bespoke post for sponsoring
this episode so the curators at bespoke
post have an all new lineup of essential
box of awesome collections for guys
guaranteed to
upgrade your life i love some of the
clothing and travel gear i've gotten
from uh bespoke posts i use this stuff
all the time
whether it's pieces to level up your
indoor hosting skills or cozy threats or
cold days
bespoke post only since guys the best
stuff every month
no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered from style and
grooming goods to cooking tools
outdoor gear box of awesomeness
collections for every part of your life
the current alchemy or polar boxes
look like some great ways to spruce up
your home bar set
up so to get started with this just take
the quiz at box of awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel
anytime each box only costs 45 bucks but
is over
70 dollars worth of gear inside get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com
and enter the code rogue at checkout
that's box of awesome.com
code rogue for 20 off your first box we
also want to thank our friends at honey
for sponsoring this episode so we all
shop online and we've all had that kind
of promo code feel
taunt us at checkout like oh you don't
know you don't know the password
you're screwed well i know i am leaving
money on the table it drives me nuts
but thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
see honey is the free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and it applies the best one it finds to
your cart at over 30 000 different
stores online
when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click
apply coupons and you wait a few seconds
as honey searches for coupons
all over the internet and if they find
one you will watch your prices
drop i saved 10 bucks on some headphones
that i bought for christmas gifts last
year
it was great honey has found its over 17
million members over 2
billion dollars in savings it took less
than a minute and was
incredibly easy every time i've used
this if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's
it's literally free and it installs in a
few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast
so get honey for free at joinhoney.com
rogue
theory that's joinhoney.com rogue theory
and new rockstars is excited to be
partnering with the app stereo
on three weekly live shows all three
shows are live on the stereo app you can
download it for free at stereo.com
new rockstars uh it's awesome it's like
a live uh
in real time podcast so you can submit
your voicemails
your comments your theories your
questions and we'll answer and respond
in real time
so these three shows on mondays we got
our editors dissecting some of their
favorite moments from the past week of
videos wednesdays
it's me and philip yesterday was me and
zach as we go through the week in
entertainment news
and on fridays jessica clements and i do
a live taping of inside marvel our one
division after show that you can hear
hours before it drops on youtube uh and
then after the show jessica and i stick
around we do a q a with everybody and
then we put that up on
youtube on sunday so if you want to be
featured on that show
you got to jump on stereo it's a great
opportunity to get
the whole world to listen to your
theories so access these live shows
share your questions and theories
interact with us in real time by
downloading this free stereo app at
stereo dot com
new that's newrockstars.stereo.com new
rockstars
uh and i want all of you to stick around
just a little later to here because i
got to tell you
about uh phillip he had an interesting
experience with blue chew
um it chokes me up okay but first
speaking
of strange masses of flesh we didn't see
coming okay we got
confirmation in episode seven that
agatha is actually
i guess somehow puppeting evan peters
his version of pietro in order to
manipulate
wanda and for many of us it makes it at
least
look a lot less like the fox x-men
quicksilver
is showing up here because he seems like
just a pawn of agatha's machinations and
she's someone who breaks the fourth wall
and it kind of seems like oh she's just
breaking the fourth wall to kind of mess
with us to do this recast
so we're we're less sure than ever what
the hell evan peters character is
the theory i pitched in the breakdown is
that he might actually be senor scratchy
the rabbit
aka agatha nicholas scratch uh
shape-shifted into a person what do you
guys think of that theory
what is pietro i like that theory but
also
i'm seven weeks in now i've been like
i'm i have to
i've already said like mafesto's in this
and at this point like i have to die on
this hill regardless of
if he's in it or not so like it's
mafesto that's all i got to say
like we're going to turn around in
episode nine there's no
mention of mafesto and people still ask
me i'm gonna be like yeah mafesto was in
it
like i am fully committed to it being
mafesto and it's just like you know that
he's
using like he's you uh agatha is using
him as a
at that body as a conduit to bring
mafesto
into this plane of existence because i
feel like you know like
the snap after the snap calls like you
know you have half of the universe going
to this
non-existent plane or this other
wherever they were at
i feel like they were where mafesto was
at and he was drawing power from all of
them and so when the snap came back
he all he lost all his power and he was
like where did all those people go so
then he's going on this digging research
and he finds out like oh
they're back on earth and now he's
working with agatha to
find out how to get to this existence so
he can draw more power
that's what i'm thinking and i'm hoping
so and i hope it's a good theory because
you know like like i said again
he has to be in this at this point i've
said it too many times so i'm i'm a i'm
like how scarlett wish came like she can
manifest kids i'm manifest
mafesto being in this series just
uh well just like you're gonna die on
the mephisto
hill i'm gonna die on the maybe agatha's
not
so bad hill because maybe agatha has
created because you know wanda doesn't
know
how this started where this happened
maybe agatha is a part of creating this
bubble
so that wanda can feel her feelings and
go through the grief
and part of that is her getting over her
brother's death which is clearly not
over yet
so this is all something agatha is
puppeting
and and he even says like i'm here to
cause you grief
and like maybe grief not in the way of
like
frustration but like grief in the way of
like letting her feel her feels and go
through those feelings
so maybe this is all just part of
wanda or uh agatha helping wanda
get through this with the least amount
of damage possible
and it's out of her hands now and it's
out of control and perhaps she
was really just trying to do right by
her buddy wumbo
you know well i think and i think that's
um totally possible danny i just want to
know what exactly
evan peters is like is he uh like a
therapy doll or it's like point two
to evan peters where you were a meat
puppet he's a full-on meat puppy
gross um here i think
i have i have problems with all these
ideas but i also love all these ideas
my only issue with him being senor
scratchy the rabbit
is the geography of that final scene and
then the post-credits scene now
that post-credit scene where monica
opens up the cellar doors and looks down
there and
all of a sudden piece was right next to
her snoopers gonna snoop or whatever
he said to her like that could have been
the next day
after wanda wanders into the basement or
it could have been
you know hours later but it seemed like
it was almost immediately after
wanda and um agatha
confront each other in the basement and
monica right she'd just been kind of
beaten up in the yard
when uh her and wanda kind of tussled
right she wasn't that far away
so it seemed like it happened right
after and like we saw senior scratchy in
a cage
in the living room and then all of a
sudden quicksilver's outside
next to monica so i don't think i
i person i choose not to believe the
rabbit and people are the same person
but
i do think i i i like some of the
theories that are out there that
agatha might be like a witch who's like
left over from the salem witch trials
somehow right like that's kind of
a little bit of a backstory in the uh
comics and maybe
um pietro what he technically is when
you kind of
peel back the fake face of evan peters
or whatever
is kind of like hurt her igor
from like you know the 1500s or whenever
the hell right like her little servant
or
or like you know puppet or whatever guy
that's been serving her for you know
centuries or something like that
is always forced to do these tricks
because i think they've made a point of
making
pietro is sentient right he keeps
calling stuff out unlike
all the other characters in west view
right like he keeps being like what are
you going to kill your husband again
no other characters besides monica have
acknowledged the outside world inside of
westview
at all even vision right has not so i
think that's important and i think like
he is not a resident of west view i
don't
he's not a multiverse quicksilver but i
think he might have like
traveled to west view with agatha maybe
he's been her companion
or servant may not like her and he maybe
resents her and he might help
monica fight her to kind of like break
the spell maybe to release himself or
something like that
but that's what i'm going with what
pietro is as far as casting goes i feel
like the creators were just trying to be
cheeky to play off this whole show and a
show and a show
sitcom kind of thing because i was
reading an interview with the showrunner
and
and she said she thought casting aaron
taylor johnson would be confusing
and i'm like and this isn't confusing
but i think they were really trying to
be
like cheeky and like winky to the
audience like a
fun and i think they innocently thought
that perhaps it would just be like a fun
little crossover that didn't mean much
uh
and i think they were sorely mistaken
obviously
yeah i don't think he i i don't think
he's x-men quicksilver but i do like
piggybacking off of what you said zach
about like him being sentient and him
kind of knowing what's going on that
kind of like
makes me even more think he's mafesto
because there was one scene
like when he was introduced when he was
talking to the kids and like
vision tried to get their attention but
they were fully locked in
on or on pietro and i'm i mean on fake
pietro and i mean like
if they're going to do the route where
like they're fragments of mafesto's soul
of course like those kids are going to
be more focused on him like because
they're part of like they feel more
connected to him
rather than vision like you know if you
want to break it down like oh like that
that methuselah could be like their real
father in a way
essentially so i feel like that's why
they were able to like that's why he had
their attention
and i thought that's why it's leaning
more towards him being mafesto and again
i could be reaching because i just like
like i said i'm just manifesting any
type of theory i have because
at this point he has to be it but man i
i i do agree with him being sentient and
i also agree like how you say daniel
like i think
that it's it's not fox fox's quick xmas
quicksilver
i i don't think that at all anymore yeah
i i think um and it's interesting right
because like
feige has been very very good uh
throughout all these films and like
knowing what his fans expectations
are and you have to imagine that
while jack schaefer while matt shackman
while the one division team
may be able to underestimate the way
fans would react to something
kevin feige would know exactly what that
would mean to fans to see
the fox quicksilver show up in the mcu
uh
like i get it i get why everyone and
people are coming at me hard
on twitter they're like you gave up on
our fox quicksilver i'm like
look only because the show doesn't seem
to be interested in that explanation
like as doreen was saying they're giving
us more like witchcraft and satanic
stuff
like i i'm still in the mephisto trade
but only because
all the evidence is pointing in that
direction like if they had given us
any other multiversal uh wink
anything any kind of reference to what
he had done
if they had played sweet dreams
eurythmics by the earth mix you know
if uh if they had talked about
apocalypse or just something
then i'd be like okay yeah um but as of
now
it's hard to see but do you guys think
that there could be something even if
it's like
you know they know wand is a nexus being
uh
could there be something there with
agatha being able to peer into the
multiverse and that was part of her meta
ploy like
i'm i'm screwing with you wanda i'm
taking this guy
and that's the mask i'm making for him i
mean potentially because in my mind like
speaking of like just the the fourth or
the fourth wall breaker like the
multiverse dimensions because when you
look on the outside of the
the whole hex it's red it's big and all
of that but as like monica was breaching
through
all blue and all she could see inside
was blue and purple which makes me think
it's like that's agatha actually like
controlling everything and manifesting
everything and it's just
she's using scarlet she's sourcing
scarlet witch's powers or she's like
being able to i don't know how she's
able to do it but she's taking how
wanda feels and then distributing it out
to everybody which makes everybody think
it's wanda's wand is the one controlling
everybody or making everybody feel like
how they feel but it's actually just
agatha using her as a conduit to just
make sure everybody feels the same way
and then they're blaming it all in wanda
but that's what i'm thinking i'm
thinking like she
like and then we also look at it when
monica was like passing through when she
had all of her
like different timelines like all of her
four different like layered like how
she's been like
evolving out throughout her life like
all those like kind of merge into one
and that's kind of like
her powers are she's able to draw from
different multi or
to draw from different universes to like
kind of that's how she's able to use her
power so i feel like
that was her kind of absorbing all the
different all her different timelines
alternate
realities into one like one being and
that's why like her eyes were going but
she's like all right
fully charged now let me break through
this wall that's like that's stopping me
and that's how
like you know like that's how it was
like how she was birthed i don't know
again feel like i'm reaching but
that's that's just my theory i mean we
all gotta reach until we have something
that's coming for you
like mr fantastic
um well i think uh there's some great
conversation there i feel like i'm a
little bit closer to understanding what
pietro could be
uh but the point is gonna go to dorian
here because it's not just because you
know my bias is mephisto i
i want mephisto to be in this too but
like you actually get with a really good
theory there
for why mephisto is in here the fact
that he was able to hold on to the souls
of the damned during the blip i
love that idea i've never thought of
that before but that's so cool that
mephisto was the one holding on to them
before they re-dusted back into reality
that's so cool
but i do like agree with zach i think
there was a more i hope we get to see
bear immortal because it's like
you know you he's been gone for a minute
now like and what was he doing in those
five years i don't think he got snapped
maybe he was making deals with
other demons and stuff like that so i
would love to see him pop up because you
know i think he's a great actor and we
need more we need more villains like
that
all right so uh before we move on uh i
promised it and i'm delivering it we
gotta talk about blue chews thank you to
blue chew for sponsoring this episode so
our friends at blue chew have
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but
in chewable form at the fraction of the
cost so bluechu is an online
prescription service so no doctor's
office or pharmacy trips it ships right
to your door in a discrete package you
sign up at bluechew.com you consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength so new rockstar's own
philip molina tried blue chew
and he said he really enjoyed the
experience he said the uh blood went to
all the right places
and he loves to bring that up in
meetings in ways that are probably not
safe for work
uh and still extremely awkward um but
it's what he experienced and we're proud
of his success so we'll just say
that he endorses blue chews products
hard pun intended
uh so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and we've got a special deal
for our listeners here's what you do you
try bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code rogue at
checkout
just pay five dollars in shipping that's
bluechu.com promo code rogue to receive
the first month free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode all right it's time for
rogue
questions so uh tom holland who just
released some photos for spider-man 3.
we're excited to look at those
uh he said an interview this week that
wanda vision is his favorite marvel
thing he has ever seen
i might have to agree until the finale
episode in which i might vehemently
disagree we'll see
but um i want to know from you guys
which one of
uh tom holland's spider-man co-stars
should be the most offended
oh yeah because he just dissed
everything he's been in right this dude
was an endgame and he's like
one division's the best marvel thing
i've ever seen you were in endgame dude
you were in spider-man far from home
maybe he doesn't like to watch himself
so maybe he hasn't seen those
i'd probably be robert downey jr i'd be
like well i was in a movie with you like
like i was your mentor like i basically
birthed you like i'm
your i'm your uncle ben in this universe
and you're just gonna tell me to decide
i don't know i'd probably be robert
downey you hear from me i don't know
probably agree oh yeah yeah i was gonna
go with
for sure zendaya i was 100
gonna go with zendaya because she is
a a great actress be a stunner and see
like gotta be a gem to work with like
she seems like the nicest person on the
universe yeah you know what just because
i
try to say her name every time i can on
on anything marisa tome
my girl my god s uh marissa may been
with her since
my cousin vinnie and damn it put some
respect on her name tom holland
and we just can tom hall and stop just
doing press for until the movie comes
out like bro like
anytime he does press for cherry or
something like that they just anybody
everybody's gonna ask ask marvel stuff
if i was them i'd just be like
no more press for me i got it i got too
big of a milestone just let me let me
know
and then there's like a ton of freaking
scoops that we have to
debunk whenever he says something and
it's like now
just wait till trailer comes out and
then you can react to the trailer tom
holland
please stop doing interviews until the
trailer comes out please all right the
point there's going to zach i believe
marissa tomei
attention must be paid yes
okay and another question here the
marvel must-haves merch line released a
three-piece
one division wedding ring set this week
considering the state of both characters
as of episode vii
is it weirder to wear vision or wanda's
wedding ring
and is there a worse couple to use the
wedding rings on
this doomed couple you can have your
rings inspired by this android
i don't know about that in my life you
know like depending on the season finale
but
just in general like there if you look
back at their relationship as a whole
they've had some they've had a rocky
start a rocky middle and
now like it's been rough like i don't
know she murdered him i'm gonna use that
as a model for like a perfect
relationship
i don't think i would want my wedding
rings to be based off of
uh rob and to lisa stark
yeah they'd be pretty bad i just feel
like it's kind of setting up
the wedding this is a not a good day not
a fun day
yeah yeah that's a great answer uh yeah
because have
technically wanda and vision have never
been officially married right they
didn't
there wasn't an engagement they didn't
have a ceremony or anything like that
well within that
comment yeah well in the comics they
were married they had a
double wedding in the comics i think but
not in the mcu unless you consider the
hex cannon but i don't think the hex is
canon well
it's weird it's a weird version of canon
she threw him through the ground in
civil war like people don't forget that
like
he's been abused like he has he's trying
he has trauma bro like if i
like i'm rooting for a boy vision though
like he just he seemed like he'd be a
good like you know
he wouldn't cheat on you or anything
like he he will he'd be a good household
keeping the kids at home while wanda's
out doing all her
sorcery and witchery so i don't know
well hopefully if he makes it through
they really pursue couples therapy
because i think at this point they could
really
really benefit from that maybe that's
the big finale maybe it's a wedding
scene
uh being officiated by patrick stewart
as professor x
right like oh what a weird wedding
why is he there but and magneto gave her
away
um the point's gonna go to danielle
there i think the rob and talisa stark
wedding theme would be pretty stupid and
awful
uh so you get the point that's so funny
uh
okay but based off my tally i believe
dorian is our winner
congratulations sir you win anything in
life so this is this is needed
it was dory and all along
um well congratulations to all of you
a bunch of great theories and thoughts i
love this episode
i can't wait to see episode eight
tonight uh let's see how right we were
in these final two episodes um so uh be
sure to
follow all of our guests dorian parks
danielle spiso and zack huddleston on
all their social media support all their
many projects everything else they're
working on uh all three are great
um support our channel by checking out
one of our many great merch options at
new yorkstarsmerch.com
you can follow me at ea boss and follow
new rockstar subscribe here on youtube
and then
one more reminder to download the stereo
app you just go to stereo.comrockstars
so you can listen to our three new
weekly live shows
download this app for free on apple and
android create an avatar and profile
and uh we'll be live on stereo 8 am
tomorrow morning jessica and i do talk
about episode 8 of wanda vision
you're going to want to be there to hear
our thoughts and get your questions
submitted so it'll be on the sunday
pop-out q a show
thank you everybody we'll see you next
time enjoy wanda vision tonight
bye
[Music]
you